peace be on to you welcome to the Dean
show thank you for tuning in this week
we have an exciting episode as always we
got a former pastor we got pastor
Coppedge on the Dean show we're going to
be talking to him his experience is
we're going to talk about you know this
is hit show out there it's called
preachers of a late we come to hustlers
of a lay there are Hollywood preachers
and they're pimping the Bentley's
pimping the Ferraris so we're going to
be talking to our guests Pastor Coppedge
here on the D show to get his
perspective so we can all benefit from
don't go anywhere
we're going to be right back for this
exciting episode of this show soon
this is the this is the video this is
the thing is the thing is the video this
is the humic a lot like concern on
rahmatullah wa but I've had to former
pastor Coppedge yes and here on a Dean
show hummed in-law you saw some of these
clips you see you know the preachers and
and the pastor's in LA Hollywood style
they got the Bentley's where you riding
at cruising a Bentley back when you were
passed there no I was it no I wasn't but
now it looks nice but I wasn't next I
mean everybody likes nice things
yeah nice things but I called this mean
the hustlers overlay because you know
there's a lot of hustling going on here
people getting ripped off and people you
know doing some things obviously I have
no doubt that Jesus peace be upon him if
he was alive today one the one who we
love we believe he was one of the
mightiest messengers of the crater sent
that you know you now as a Muslim you
you understand his true mission but
would Jesus agree with a lot of these
things that are going on today know in
his name of course not - please tell us
why okay because what what Jesus he
loves he loves simplicity okay I need a
lot of people to to give to the poor and
we never exploited the poor by taking
what they give to us to the turtle you
for yourself so you think that's a lot
of this is going on when we see people
are actually giving money and then not
now these guys are taking that money who
is supposed to go back into the
community and I'm sure maybe a small
part does but man when you look at some
of these houses these are like
multi-million dollar houses family
200,000 strong extravagance isn't it
right so this wouldn't be some
acceptable wouldn't know let me know so
tell us you you so you are part of a
nonde nominally congregation okay of the
non-denominational pastor okay of a
Church of Christ and it was located in
Chicago and the congregation was a small
congregation maybe a hundred - between
one hundred hundred and fifty members in
the community and I used to teach God's
plan of salvation and which was to hear
God's Word to believe it okay then one
must repent have a change of heart the
one must confess and then one must be
baptized this is what I used to teach
now we're going to look at this clip
right now why you say Lord Jesus Georgie
forgive me for my sins forgive me for my
sin I believe in my heart I believe that
Jesus Christ that she died for my sins
in Jesus name I'm safe I'm safe okay so
now in the clip you saw that was like is
that what we're talking about used to
teach like what he was saying that okay
in Jesus name I believe in my heart and
that I repent two huge everything is
about Jesus now Jesus being God Jesus
repenting you repenting to Jesus this is
what you used to change yes it is that's
what I usually yeah so now what would
you as as a because obviously now you're
a Muslim one who submits to the will of
God and we believe as Muslims that Jesus
was a Muslim Abraham Moses because they
all submitted to God what's the
difference now the difference now is
that God does not have sons okay and
Jesus we wouldn't consider him as a son
of God we consider him as a prophet as a
messenger and we also know that Jesus
taught complete submission to God's will
and that's aslam now where do people get
this idea where would you say now as a
pastor former pastor you know you are
preaching and teaching a lot of this
this stuff that goes far away from the
true teachings of pure monotheism
worshiping the crater alone not as
Christian where where do people get some
of these evidences from obviously from
the Bible but you know how do they go so
far away from the true teaching because
I mean it seems quite simple worship the
Creator not his creation but how do you
go to give all of these rights that
belong to the crater to Jesus now
because they pushed it and they changed
the word from their right places
and that's how they do it yeah so you
got to see this firsthand yes I got to
translate this word to give us give us
some some some details like you give us
some some things that you can elaborate
more on this okay when it comes down to
Presbyterian churches or I would say a
sanctified Church and you have people
that are speaking in tongues okay of
course I was a non-denominational pastor
and we didn't believe that speaking in
tongues was authoritative
because in the Bible it says that if any
man speaking an unknown tongue let it be
by 2 or bought be by 3 and let one
interpret that there'd be no interpreter
then that'll keep silent in the church
but in the sanctified Church they teach
that a person has the ability to speak
in tongues and they and by using this
theatrics
they then convince the people that they
are true they are right and that you
should give to their calls now the more
important thing is that we know that
throughout time obviously the Creator
out of his loves or God so loved the
world that he sent prophets and
messengers to guide mankind listen you
were at one time preaching and teaching
that for God so loved the world that He
sent His only begotten Son and what what
is that what does that actually implied
now talk about this that implies that
that God has sons right now believed
that that would imply the gods had sons
daughters nieces nephews uncle's
auntie's a beginning in a mother and a
father but God doesn't have all of that
hold on but someone says hold on it just
says his son how did you get auntie
uncle cousin Ken Kent how did you get
all that from this because if I was to
believe that God had a son I had to
believe that God had a daughter as well
and if I believe he had a daughter I
believe that he had a cousin that had a
uncle that he had a auntie that he had
all these things and which doesn't
really too much make sense we can't
attribute that to God know in Islam as
you cut all that off
yeah no children God is God doesn't have
any children
okay God is if there's nothing
comparable not to him mm-hmm and God
said he is one the irresistible he
begets not nor is He begotten that none
and unto him that that's pretty
straightforward simple as the message
that all the messengers of God came so
when you when you examine this verse
that God so loved the world that He sent
His only Son whoever believes in him how
does the rest of the risco the who
believe in will have everlasting life
no can't we say is muslims dead hey I
mean we would qualify more for this
because a if you say believe in Jesus we
it's an article of faith to believe that
he was one of the mightiest messengers
of God so we believe in him we do
believe in Jesus and doesn't it doesn't
say anywhere in this verse that now that
you have to believe that he's God
incarnate that he's a literal son of God
that he died for your sins it doesn't it
doesn't even say that in that verse does
it no it doesn't and no one knows until
the very end when the day of judgment
who's gonna have everlasting good life
but whether it's going to be a good life
or a bad life after and an afterlife
no one knows until the day of judgment I
mean the only one who has that authority
now to give visas to to paradise or the
Hellfire is the Creator yes correct
yeah but the guidelines obviously are
there what qualifies one obviously what
we need to do to achieve that ultimate
reward in the next and what we have to
do to stay away from the Hellfire that's
pretty clear isn't that crystal clear
and now one of the ultimate things that
now all the messengers call people way
to away from and please ever sighs this
is setting up a partner with God we call
every ship yeah
and this associating partner because God
doesn't have any partners
yeah he's one he is the creator
everything else has created hmm so when
we come back I want to ask you we talked
about these lay preachers even the
Hollywood preachers and can you can you
relate to that is that kind of like the
style that you were you were nowhere
near that no no we're nowhere near that
because of nondenominational
Christianity
all of that is looked down upon as far
as people who tricked the hearts and the
minds of me and in order to have
personal gain mmm-hmm how about if
someone says look you you are changed or
you went in another direction now you
didn't have the Holy Ghost
you weren't full of the Holy Spirit what
would you say to that I would ask them
to the family what
all the gold is and has someone to find
out - you know they haven't been able to
do that yet no okay we're going to be
right back with more with former pastor
Coppedge here on the Deen show right
back so cool who Allah who had say he
lost one God is one
the maker of mankind exactly a lot who's
somewhat lost self-sufficient
he doesn't need food or drink he doesn't
need to rest on the seventh day okay I
really had a problem with that even
before I knew anything about Islam God
resting sounds like a weak God yeah
Lamia lit well I'm you let he begets not
he doesn't have any children nor was he
a child or born of anything or anyone
well I'm yeah cool I hope to fly and
there's nothing co-equal or comparable
to him at all nobody nothing Jesus
no nobody nobody is comparable to the
crater nothing yeah and that right there
was in his essence what I believe
naturally
you
back here on the D show with former
pastor Coppedge now tell us a little bit
more about you because it's really
unique
you know people hear so many negative
things nowadays through the media about
Islam and now they see hold on what's
going on why would this guy you know
who's a Christian why would he accept
Islam I accepted Islam because when at
the end of my pastorship as a Christian
pastor well-taken I knew that when I
first was studying to be a pastor that I
wanted to live a life of righteousness I
want to live for God okay no matter
where was going to be so if it wasn't
with Christianity I knew would be with
another religion and so I knew this so
at the end of my package ship when I was
forced to resigned okay I did some
soul-searching and then I read some
books and I read some books one was
called it was called message to the
black man by Elijah Muhammad that was
the first book that I read on Islam and
so I took this book to the Masjid they
told me that has some truth in it but
it's really not the truth about Islam
and if you want to learn we're going to
teach you and so then the the master
that they taught me what Islam was about
and they gave me some books by a brother
named Ahmed Deedat and when I read his
books the first book I read was
crucifixion or crucifixion and it was
spared crucifixion with the X or
crucifixion like fiction and nonfiction
and this particular book it convinces
one with the Bible that the crucifixion
didn't really take place in the way the
Bible that said and so then I had to go
further and I said this is really
interesting okay this must be the truth
and so then I would have searched a
little bit further and then what
happened and then what happened was I
was convinced that Islam was the way of
life because it was more it was more
structured it told me how to eat it told
me how to sleep it taught me how to walk
it
show me how to talk and and it told me
how to do everything leave nothing no
stone unturned and so these things were
very easy for me to understand and the
one part that really convinced me is
when I read about the creation of the
baby in the womb of the mother who's
pregnant
and it goes very detailed about how the
baby has formed in the womb now this was
1,400 years ago
medical science is not really it just
recently found this out and when I read
that I know that this was the truth you
said also in speaking before that you
actually when someone starts to give you
references from the Bible where it says
that and they tried to substantiate this
claim that Jesus was actually the
literal son of God that he was one with
God so they say that okay Jesus said
that I and the father are one no one
comes to the Father except through me
they say that in the beginning was the
word the Word was with God and the word
became flesh so there's other verses
that people will use and say look you
know you're actually wrong
pastor copied your former pastor copies
you know you got to come back to
Christianity because you didn't see
these verses what would you say the
first thing I were the first thing I say
to them that the Bible was not revealed
in English and that whenever you read
something in a language other than what
we revealed you relied upon the
translators okay and the things that you
say that the Bible said in English
Jesus himself he'd never said and when
we go back to the originals of the
Hebrew into the Greek we find out that
the words have been changed to the point
that if you've won the Old Testament
Hebrews okay in A Song of Solomon it
says in the English okay so lovely as he
and if you look at the Hebrew is used
the word [ __ ] okay so the Prophet
Muhammad was Richard by name in the
Hebrew Old Testament but they translated
names
just like they translated Peter in the
New Testament as the rock so this is
what happened so you have a lot of
mistranslation you have actually a lot
of addition I mean we'll go to a clip
right now this is like one of the top
by Bible scholars in the world today
used to also be a former Christian and
again we never want to you know belittle
anybody or disparage on anybody it's
really just trying to get people to
think think out the box and that's what
you did so we're gonna go to this clip
real quick and this is what this Bible
scholar has to say about the Bible today
for a long time I thought that the Bible
was inspired and inerrant that there
were no mistakes in the Bible but as I
engaged in historical research on the
Bible as I was getting my PhD in New
Testament Studies at Princeton
Theological Seminary I started finding
mistakes in the Bible and this this cut
away at my assumptions that the Bible
was inerrant and then I started
questioning other parts of my faith is
Jesus really divine is a really a
Trinity so now in contrast to the Quran
we know the Quran we have in its
original tamper free tamper-proof it's
one of the living miracles but here when
people see this you know this is a
scholar of Christianity of the Bible he
said we don't have a copy of a copy of a
copy of any original Bible or anything
close of that did you know that at that
time and you were a pastor at first I
didn't but later I found out that we
didn't have the originals of the Bible
mm-hmm and we had and we relied upon
that that what we had and that that's
what I was convinced to believe that
what we have was all we can work with
and that was God that was his choice to
give it give that to us but there's
there's also another verse that people
use when you bring this up that whoever
changes anything that the wrath of God
will be upon them
let us revelation 22 verse 18 and verse
94 this is when God when John was
banished to the island of Patmos he
revealed this is therefore if I testify
to any man if he added to the worst of
the book of this prophecy
I shall added him the plagues that are
written in this book If any man shall
take away from the words of the book of
this prophecy
I said take his name out of the book of
life out of the holy city and out of the
things that are written therein so what
do you say when someone uses this as
they say they use this as evidence that
the Bible hasn't been chained
okay basically this was description was
used by the nondenominational Christians
to say that you couldn't add to the
worship or take away from the worship
service as pertaining to God because
what what the different denominational
churches do they add things into the
worship service that was not originally
a part of what the Bible said so this is
what's description was useful I mean and
do you think like a lot of these pastors
like these LA preachers now do you think
many of them capitalize on the people's
ignorance now because it's like a
feel-good philosophy you come into the
church it's like a discotheque a
nightclub again we're not trying to just
put you know disparage or on anybody but
think that the Box everybody's dancing
and what do you thoughts on this yeah
this theatrics okay it's entertainment
this is show okay and people want to be
entertained they will pay to be
entertained the the entertainment
industry makes billions of dollars every
year because people thrive off
entertainment but now I mean again
you're playing with the way of life
that's not supposed to be played with
drew this is the truth you know that
sent down from the Creator through all
the messengers and we're not to be
tampering with it taking it to a
nightclub and doing all these other
things know if it's the truth you have
to protect it and save it and not just
modify it to fit your people's desires
right that's true yeah so we got some
more you can stick around for some more
yes we're gonna go take a break all
right and God willing we'll be right
back to talk to former pastor a cottage
here on the Dean show on and then the
son of the Prophet slice alone the fact
that you have an application so you have
you know the beauty of this film is that
not only is our text our Scripture
preserved so flawlessly but the
interpretation of the scripture is
preserved so flawlessly which is the
profits on the long body incentives
example the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him as I shall be aloha and may
Allah be pleased with her explain today
you know I explained he was a walking ad
which is so if I can't understand this
word I can just go to the prophets
Lysanne life and I can see I can see
even the sunnah has been preserved back
here on the Deen show and we're trying
to get people to think out the box right
yep so let's all give a live visual here
we have the Catholic Bible and this one
is 66 yes so this is the King James so
now you have this book the Revised
Standard Version this is 1952 and when
we open it up we see that they tell us
that these are like 32 scholars of the
highest eminence you know backed by 50
cooperating nominations like the highest
church they say that the King James
Version has graves defect so many so
serious as to call for a revision so we
did you know that the King James Version
now this one is thrown thrown out
they've thrown out what was in this
Bible and in the King James Version
there's grave defects so many so serious
that now there's like some some trouble
here I mean did you say things about
they no thank speaking about English
uh-huh and and the King James Bible was
written in 1611 yeah and then speaking
about English and they speaking about
another English Bible they're vast and
eversion and none of the gods men who
just spoke English no so what are they
talking about mm-hmm so how do how did
you make sense of this
ah now that now what was this transition
that you made did was this like a
stepping stone that you know you used to
come to Islam how did you because you
obviously started studying and finding
all these things out how did you end up
yes Christianity was used as a stepping
stone to Islam most definite it was not
a stumbling block because everything
that I've learned as far as being Muslim
in the Quran it verifies some of the
things that I've learned in Christianity
okay and it's it's more similarities
than differences
yeah and the ones that are true Muslims
who are sincerely seeking to serve Allah
and the ones who are sincerely from the
best of our ability if I was knowing
that they strive to be a good Christians
they are cook they're close to one
another okay in a lawful Matata
he tells us that the Christians are
closest coming to the muscles yeah and
that's why I mean that's why it's out of
this love that we have for you know our
brothers in humanity that we want to
bring these things to light showing
people that Jesus peace be upon him we
love Him you can go to head to the help
people don't know that if you obviously
if you don't believe in Jesus because
one of the articles of face to believe
in the messengers Jesus be one of those
messengers so as a Muslim if you don't
believe in all the money and all the
messengers reject one reject them all
you you that's a one-way ticket to the
Hellfire is that not that's true yeah so
we love Jesus do we do with those so do
you we love him in the best sense yes
because we love in the message that he
taught in the true sense yeah and none
of the things that they may have changed
as far as the Bible is concerned to say
that he said this and we know that he
didn't say that because even in the
Quran Allah stone our toddler he tells
us that he's going to don't y'all
makigami he's going to question he's
going to ask Jesus did he say this or
did he say that not because Allah
doesn't know but because he's going to
profess this in front of the people he'd
come here did you say that you was the
son of God did you did you tell them to
worship you and Jesus is going to say I
never said such things
hmm so this is like an event
that's going to happen in the future
that on the day of judgment God is going
to ask did you say to the people to take
me and my mother is God's next to God he
says no way below I never said that no
way
I mean no way Jose right you know right
there's no way he called you to worship
one God and your God
right right right that's in the Lord's
Prayer isn't it yes where's my father
what in heaven is that it say that in
the Lord credible even though we don't
call a lot of father yeah
some scholars say that you know because
there's such a similarity between an
Arabic it's up father and Lord is up so
they also could have messed this up well
it's not all my lord who was who art in
heaven hallowed be thy name and there's
no problem with this is a great prayer
for would you say a Christian to start
if he's because you see Christians many
people praying through Jesus why don't
they stick with this prayer you know and
not bring a middle man in the middle
this could be a start for God
facilitating a way of guidance right
most definitely yeah because go ahead
this let's talk about this briefly this
Lord's Prayer says it's it's all praise
to the to the one creator without prayer
to God that to God what you call upon
God asking for guidance
definitely he'll facilitate away is that
right yes that's true yeah did you make
this prayer a lot no no I didn't make
that prayer lot and non-denominational
Christianity is quite different than not
denominational Christianity and a lot of
things that we see today
it's like none of them not
denominational Christianity's it is in
the back it's you can't see what's going
on what do you mean
meaning that is hidden from the populace
it's hidden from the people because the
smallest churches the smallest
congregations are the Churches of Christ
the only church name that's mentioned in
the Bible is Church of Christ it's no
other name that's mentioned presbyterian
such-and-such a source or Church these
names are not mentioned in the Bible
yeah okay and so the nondenominational
Christianity is very small but the
denominational Christianity is very big
and
the most followers and produces the most
confusion among the people yeah
so what was it finally they had you
accept this way of life that obviously
Jesus was upon Jesus submitted not to
himself not to anything in creation he
submitted to the will of God that's
Islam one word sums it all up so what
finally had you accept Islam well
finally had me accept Islam is after our
studies with Imam Ibrahim okay and this
was at mosque
Umar on the southside of Chicago and
after he gave me the book on crucifixion
or crucifixion it really solidified my
understanding that this was the way of
God this was the little the right way
because everything that the Christian
faith stands upon is based upon the
crucifixion everything without the
crucifixion Christianity won't exist
without everything that's attached to
him dying upon the cross for our sins
without that Christianity won't exist so
once I was shown from this particular
book that the crucifixion didn't happen
in the way that they say it happened
with the evidence from the Bible itself
it made me understand and believe that
Islam is a complete way of life and this
is what I chose to to believe in and to
accept and to adopt to my life how about
this concept also of someone dying for
your sins you mentioned that you really
weren't even convinced of this as a
pastor is that right as a pastor I
didn't believe that Jesus Christ died
for my sins because in one place that
said that in another place it says that
every man must bear his own burden and
these two things seemed like they was
contradictory because if you're going to
vary members bears on his bears alone
burden then how could one man better
burden of all yeah so you have a
conflict you have a contradiction there
right and in Islam the way of life that
you know all the messengers talk brought
personal accountability god is the
most-loving you turn to them
and you repent sincerely and he forgives
all sins right and all and in Islam as
well every man was better on Berg yeah
that makes sense so I'm the liar you're
kuma
thank you for being with us we got to
walk around the time that the creator of
heavens the earth reward you we started
with peace we ended with peace peace be
with you
Salaam alaikum alaikum Salaam and thank
you for tuning in to another episode of
the Deen show some of these things we
bring to light to really have you think
out of the box now let me give you an
example imagine someone bought you
something real simple like a cup of
coffee and everyone was pointed to you
wonder where this cup of coffee is
coming from and everyone's pointing to
the to the gentleman over there but now
that person instead of thinking you you
know you just look past you and didn't
even sign didn't even smile
you know you'd really think wouldn't a
not so nice person I was going to say
arrogant but what a not so nice person
that's just a cup of coffee what about
the one who gave you the ability to
taste this coffee the one who gave you
the taste buds with the over a hundred
taste cells so I mean do we really
ponder and think for all the blessings
of the maker of mankind has given us and
what better way to thank him then
acknowledging him and his favours upon
us and thanking him directly and alone
and that was the message that all of the
messages including Jesus he called
people to only worship the Creator to
give all praise and thanks to the
Creator not to himself not to put him as
a middleman next to God make him one in
three in a Trinity no
he called people to worship only God and
so did the last and final messenger said
to mankind who was the brother to Jesus
problem and peace be upon him and Moses
Abraham and all the other countless
messengers that the Creator sent to out
of his love to guide humanity so if
you're one of our Christian brothers who
are tuning in brothers in humanity why
don't you start with this simple prayer
that's in the Bible
it's the Lord's Prayer
calling upon the one maker or Lord who
art in heaven o my Creator who art in
heaven hallowed be thy name thy kingdom
come meaning that you're the owner of
everything that exists that all praises
to you you're glorifying God that is a
commonality between us that we can build
on and if you thank your creator and you
ask him the same way that Jesus was
teaching you in the Bible Jesus never
taught you to put him in the middle and
go through him know straight to God
direct dialogue and that makes sense
that makes sense
try that if there's any other things
that you'd like to have us cover here on
the Dean show also you can follow us on
the Facebook Twitter give us your
suggestions how many topics that you'd
like to see us cover and I hope that
this show has had you think out of the
box and hopefully is of some benefit and
we hope to see you again next time
until then peace be unto you